i am so grateful to all my staff and the
fans in this country and around the
world
who have joined me in this really crazy
and seemingly
pointless pursuit conan o'brien's nearly
three decade long stint as a late night
host is over
the 58-year-old tv personality said
goodbye to his long-running tbs series
conan
on thursday night i have devoted all of
my adult life
all of it to pursuing this
strange phantom intersection between
smart and stupid
um and there's a lot of people that
believe the two cannot co-exist
but god i will tell you it is something
that i believe religiously
i think when smart and stupid come
together it's very difficult but if you
can make it happen i think it's the most
beautiful thing
in the world and he couldn't sign off
without his famous comedian friends like
will ferrell
you know i was there for your final late
night show
and your last tonight show episode and
now this one yeah that's true it's kind
of become a tradition
i'll tell you what it is it's exhausting
jack black stopped by too and revealed
that his first appearance on late night
tv was with o'brien
and i was scared as hell i was petrified
i'd never been in front of a late night
audience before
and you were so smart and funny and kind
it was the best way to like enter the
late night television world
and i will always feel a special
connection with you and worship you
and in a nod to conan's star in comedy
as a writer for the simpsons
homer simpson himself showed up as an hr
rep
ready to give conan his exit interview
how long have you been working at
tibbs i think you mean tbs uh thanks for
the help smart guy but i think i know
how to spell
tibs many stars also posted touching
tributes on instagram
including rhys witherspoon the actress
wrote what a brilliant kind hysterically
funny
and genuinely curious late night host he
always listened to my crazy stories and
laughed at my weird jokes
every time i came around for a visit
thank you conan and the whole at team
coco for keeping us laughing for so many
years
well i've been in show business now 45
seconds and this is the nicest reception
i ever had
thank you very much before conan o'brien
hosted late night with conan o'brien
from 1993
to 2009. there will be gas there will
also be you know comedy
uh it'll be a mixture you know of those
things after he moved on to host the
tonight show
but his run ended after less than a year
in 2010 he came back with conan
the end of the tbs show was announced in
november 2020.
when your real goal is just to think
about comedy and think about something
funny
that's all that's all it is to me but
this isn't the last fans will see of
o'brien
he's headed to hbo max for a weekly
variety series it means i've overstayed
my welcome
i think and before he said his official
goodbye
o'brien left fans with words of
encouragement
try and do what you love with people you
love
and if you can manage that it's the
definition of heaven on earth i swear to
god it really is so good night thank you
very much